blog mas numero 11 io mi rendo conto di
trovarmi davanti a un piccolo problema
questa casa ormai non sta più in piedi
mi rinchiuso in camera mia a volte per
ora di non avere a che fare con gli
altri sto qui siamo personaggi che sotto
sotto un mistero anche un po sulle balle
perchè sono i miei animali domestici che
se arrivano tranquillamente guarda ti
piace vedere lui ci ha proprio lasciati
cioè lui ormai ci danno conte non ce la
fa più a convivere con tutta sta gente
ti prego portami via trend e se cerca di
trovare ogni tanto una botola che possa
espellere la da questo posto cioè tu hai
un primo piano veramente sembri mete
fotogenica quasi quanto me specialmente
a questa posizione culto in tutto questo
e sotto con enrico pare i suoi bisogni
perché ho detto basta non ce la fa
questa è la situazione della mia stanza
quest'angolo che potrebbe sembrare
l'angolo della roba vecchia ro.la
in realtà è un enorme costruzione una
ziggurat per evitare che guidò arrivi al
distributore automatico di cantini che
vedete lì come faccio a evitare di
creare il fosso di helm per allontare
nel mio cane da i croccantini dei gatti
è stato detto cerca di mettere tutto
quanto in una zona rialzata in modo che
non riesca a raggiungerlo ma che mi devo
comprare cioè un obelisco cioè un cubo
da mettere di lato avete magari un
consiglio una roba di ke ha che
utilizzano le che avete preso perché io
avevo bisogno di una roma molto stretta
cioè che ci salgono ciao è che possa
prendermi in palco per i gatti
io vi dico sono un po stressato non so a
chi chiedere chiedere l'aiuto alle carte
questa è una cosa che poche persone
sanno forse uno dei miei piccolissimi
petit show lezionari e tarocchi breaker
insuccesso stupende andiamo a leggere
come andrà questo blog mas prima carta e
il giurì ci guardate già con il mezzo
sembro io e il mio ex
l'uomo della mia vita non lo so seconda
carta 4 de basto è la linea quando non
si fa il silk epil l'ultima e il seste
copa strumento pensato fosse uno
specchio prima carta rappresentare
c'è poi chi ca no sto leggendo si stavo
leggendo la mia videocamera stavo così
siamo una camomilla no ma le posso avere
però un aiuto da no così non mi va bene
si riesce a essere un po più esoterica
buy
intanto vado avanti forse abbiamo
iniziato questa esperienza con giudizio
di responsabilità una voglia di
dimostrare una voglia di far bene ma
allo stesso tempo bisogno di fare meglio
rispetto agli altri anni poi c'è 4 de
bustos
non fatevi per i non preoccupatevi a
volte tornare alle origini primarie
della scimmia quattro i bastoni della
cantante della che c'è che scenica che
poi la luna le meravigliosa vieni con me
i cap
non a caso 4 siamo noi componenti io la
vigna gianmarco enrico una casualità non
credo e seste cocco questa sono io che
pianto dopo che ho pulito la lettiera
questa qui sei tu punto che piange punto
può in questo periodo sono anche io
punto questa è la carta di comanda
grandissima malinconia a ci mancherà
tanto che valentina che ogni giorno con
un travestimento ci mancherà vedere ogni
giorno gabriele che prova una sostanza
dell'alterazione della psiche diversa
non vedo l'ora che mi manca già
piangendo
andiamo arrivato il momento di
affrontare tutto quello che sta
succedendo la foto non so se lo vuoi
sapere perchè psicologici è comunque la
famiglia non serve che io vi predica il
futuro caso vediamo che cos'è che stanno
facendo vila la ruota della fortuna che
un altro modo per definirla la cagnara
bagnara pura tutto questo che sembravano
maglia io sembro federica pellegrini per
me è noto come che messo sta cosa ecco
se volete da stasera sul social viola
avrete la possibilità di avere anche
delle letture parte della maga guarda
questa è la copertina del mio disco
ultima cosa la canzone del natale 2020
di persone di questa casa dovrà comporre
anche una strofa in questa canzone modo
che diventi la nostra colonna sonora di
questo 2020 che c'è tanto piaciuto
perché non finirlo in allegria gabriele
ti vedo a pezzi pregiati bagnato cosa
legnate scarpe bagnate bagnato by
gabriele volta i porti culto cioè voglio
dì bagnato cos'è esaltati lo stai
facendo davvero i calzini con le
infradito limbi scottà riguarda no non
risentono la faccia
la sanità è breve ma sono l'anti sesso
queste cose perché si inventano si
vantano in questi sedici date sfuggire
culinario guardi devo dare un annuncio
per i nostri spettatori non è una buona
notizia
questo è il router pu cui noi
connettiamoci passiamo i dati è andato
in papa sandy blog ma finisce qui ma non
così stavo per chiamare
[Musica]
enrico è qualcosa da dire mi licenzio io
sto facendo per tutti quanti voi uno
spaghetti al pomodoro visto che abbiamo
assaggiato spaghetto valentina brava
l'hai certo segreta la rende un ragazzo
si mangia pubblico il secondo enrico
pensa dolce se io non c'è il secondo che
rifinanziando dopo al cuore ho esagerato
con l'area vanga ad essa cercare tanti
movimenti di stomaco vivo la carriera la
definizione che si vedeva mangiare
noccioline da minuti in acqua per
esempio rosolina bere a milano giolina
troviamo un giovane ma giornata questa
casa all'alba in forma si avvicina e
varedo anche a te la carta da struzzo
terminal 3 opportunità se la destra
struzzo
davanti al giudice trovate adesso lo
la prima nata del tuo momento
finiamola qui ci siamo riusciti a testa
una stanza con questa nostra novara il
papà ti vedono al 100 con tanto di
ripresa è questa non è la mente ma è il
mio non è bravo basta su quattro in
testa struzzo è tutto a posto ma
incrocia bene professore nome ma fanno
apposta ho capito a me sono tutto ciò
anche se la fa gli spettano
ecco un fenomeno gioco è fatto di
ripresa ribadito il video caramia video
è truccato lo tagliano l'unico molto
comuni come la casa ma con il sole di
ciabattine adesso ho trovato ma tablet o
scarto e torture lo cercava di orio alla
coscia al collo ed gancia ha inquadrato
la sua esposizione mediatica sulla
coscia la posizione
si vabbè da me ciabatte cioè testa di
struzzo qui
in una testa di strumica sono i vari mi
vedeva l'ora di gabriele qualcosa tra di
loro nessun errore
e stato mano giocata migliore non sono
una testata struzzo era guglielmo che mi
faceva i lanci sbagliati a porta sì ho
buttato più spazzatura io in questi
giorni che che l'ama cioè per monetario
da casa 8 eccomi il babbo natale
dell'immondizia è che i bambini di
scampia
e allora quando non ci va di fare le
cose dobbiamo farli divertendoci quindi
voglio aprire il secchio provare a fare
tutto un tiro da tre così angolato
sicuramente se sbaglio però ci prova
anche 123 a
niente difficile questa attività
sportiva e difficile già l'attivita
sportiva e difficile in sé in più quando
si riprende è doppiamente difficile 12
un bello a sprazzi abbiamo bisogno che
tu mi riprende venga con me aspetta
scusa io 6 cabrio e sullo sfondo mai
vestito che mancano a tel aviv via brel
oggi e scarico perché non è nella mente
dell'artista perché non ha la mente
dell'arte si è spremuto tutti i giorni
ma non riesce a mantenere la mente
dell'artista e riassicura mai e 3
la mia ragazza mi permette di fare le
cose che ci perde il tempo capito
guardiamoci del delitto di anni se alla
sac norris sta intrattenendo pallina
perché
l artista io farò arriviamo cavallino
tipo di risposta mila ragazzi non posso
vedere dell'artista nel tuo cane
funzionato alla grande niente enrico 6
nella mente dell'artista o fate vede
[Musica]
nella ripresa una meta libertà ma mi
sono lanciato visto questo pare propenso
fosse la sense album però di far vedere
ma scusa ma che sta succedendo in quella
data se della pista poco mamma mia
rischiano di spezzarsi il collo a
mettere l'artista gabriele amadori dove
stamane sono sicuramente la figlia amy
un momento di attività sono nella mente
dell'artista per riaprire quello che
avresti trovato la mente dell'artista
grazie di avermi rispecchiato la mente
dell'artista ma adesso dovrei smettere
si notano per un attimo ai buona
riflessione
bentornato paletti ben tornato tra i
denti di gabriele marini di costantino
all'aquila mente dell'artista cento
le domande vanno sempre bene insieme ma
mica vado io
chiudere la porta non sia un maschio le
prime ha rischiato in valle si è
scaricato la dignità mettetela visto
all'improvviso
l'artista di provincia la mente
dell'artista
mette le arti stati cosa sarà mai meno
io bene che è bene per favore lo so lo
so scusami se ti ho svegliato dal
torpore
dobbiamo vedere se valentina la mente
dell'artista è inutile che mi come io
non più ma dove valentina la
trasformista faccio veramente
dell'artista artista l'artista ragazzi
cd monetizza nel video valentina sì
perché a saltare dovrei avere ragione
nulla da non all'aver della iii sec
cosa che succede sento artista sentono
loro dell'artista il naso mi dici di
avviare la [ __ ] impianti ragazzi
vogliamo vedere si è preso alla
sprovvista giornata certamente
l'anchorman prima in mezzo al mar
costellato eccovi molto molto la c4 si
può divertire a fettine di garda
l'infuso della mente dell'artista il
solo imputo de marco non ha la mente
parti non c'erano all'improvviso che ce
l'ha non ce la fa guardavo mano a un
grande artista di rifiuto dell'artista
vai tu che cosa giusta ma dell'antica
primi tre sono registrate quasi
sicuramente stato un artista questo
social guarda te la faccio vedere io un
po più a morto per fare solo più brutta
partita va così al sociale di arisla
zuger vaiolo come il tuo papà bull
donava ho sentito l'esigenza invece io
di entrare nella mente del regista e
devo dire che i ragazzi siamo arrivati
alla fine di questa giornata a pezzi la
carta del quadro della stessa linea
prima del city pilla ha parlato chiaro
ha dato un suggerimento e da oggi la
chiamano anche la carta della vita
dell'artista decidiamo domani alle 14
sempre con un altro pro bass ciao